le feu a été mis dans les exploitations
se trouvant en bord de route
le ou les pyromanes n'ont pas pris le
risque de s'aventurer à l'intérieur des
champs nous avons eu de la chance que le
feu a été sous le vent dévasage que si
le vent arrivé d'en face pratiquement
tous été brûlés mais lorsque le la can
le fia le feu sous le vent elle prend du
temps et les bons pilotes à devenir puis
depuis l'été ne sait nous y avons été
chanceux la façon dont il a mené le fait
sénégalais des chansons parce que on a
pu sauver la basse elle mais ici vous
n'est pas tellement les six
exploitations touchées appartiennent au
groupe
agrican le patron n'est autre que jean
michel ayotte une parcelle appartenant à
bernard ayotte est situé non loin de
l'usiné clément a elle aussi été
incendiée alors la famille ayotte
serait-elle directement visés par ces
incendies
s'il ya des gens qui ont des messages à
faire passer c'est un peu de colère
ils ont quelque chose à dire je pense
que si peut-être pas la bonne méthode
puisque à cannes il ya des ouvriers qui
se réveille vous imaginez que si vous ne
font les la pagaille
il bougeait tout les cas nous rêver ses
ouvriers ils vont faire quoi
si je pense que c'est à leurs
compatriotes qui en veulent à et qui
vont faire du mal parce que si vous vous
les avez vous adressé aux responsables
vous allez vers les bureaux une enquête
est en cours pour déterminer les
circonstances exactes de tous ces
départs de feu